whoa and will sasso just came in hey men
will take it easy though
what all right let's start this podcast
too but first first you're gonna shut up
alright okay man no no no no no first
I'm tears bigger yeah it is if we got
you a big old you to shut up about seven
or eight seconds ago and here's the
other thing I know that on podcasts we
talk yeah it's what podcasting is all
about high chin okay well how's it going
well it's got the giggles today hi how
are you good yeah I'm will will went to
the wrong studio so he's really flying I
told you to shut the [ __ ] up and before
we get into that and we discuss that
with your audience whom you know yeah I
love and respect very much yeah yeah so
much so that especially today I almost
feel like you don't deserve them well
I'm asking you for the last time stop
talking we're gonna do a podcast first
here today you and I yeah yeah okay okay
all right
I'll tell you what that is okay
okay no I'm not asking you questions I'm
gonna tell you what it is okay today
Bryan Callen huh you're gonna take it
timeout I would ask you not to speak
anymore if it pleases ya
I mean if we're friends like you say we
are we are friends known each other a
long time shared a lot of laughs yeah so
I'm just gonna ask you to let me handle
this
for a second and what I'm gonna say it
is
we're pulling off a podcast first cuz
you're gonna take a time out Brian and
this timeout is gonna be different than
any other timeout that you've ever heard
on a podcast sure someone has to leave
during a podcast take a [ __ ] or it's not
the time for the guest to talk whether
it's not what I'm talking about usually
it's one or two people talking so you'd
probably think that in that you're not
talking then I'll be filling that space
no Brian we're both gonna take your time
and we're gonna think about what we did
to our friend we'll begin
I'm gonna take a timeout from the
timeout and suggest that perhaps you're
not thinking things through
la and you're talking again and that's
not what a timeout is any elementary
school student would tell you that so
let's just think about what happened
with our friend well for a little while
I don't know about you but I'm gonna
enjoy how comfortable this new chair is
and get the mic right here and here we
go
good so during that time bright won't
you share what you thought of okay look
that I want to apologize no don't start
with some [ __ ] apology that's hollow
you just you can't even prove to me that
you know what the [ __ ] you did for I
didn't know that I didn't tell you I
just didn't realize he you didn't know
where the new studio was and you went to
the old one and Playa Vista and then you
had to drive here and it took you about
25 minutes then about 25 minutes only
about four miles as the crow flies in LA
yeah and you know that for miles as the
crow flies in LA could take anywhere
from 15 minutes to two and a half hours
it's true man yeah so we got kind of
lucky yeah
lo lo lucky hey I got a question go
ahead what's wrong with you you know
just in general I got a long I got these
texts from you and I was excited I said
let's do the podcast and I got I just
got this you go um I go you go tomorrow
is the last step of T phat K I'm gonna
ruin your [ __ ] podcast Emily and you
call me Emma yeah and I go whoa bro come
on man what's that mean and then you go
what does anything mean and I go I don't
know what that means and then you go how
the [ __ ] should I know I must have been
confused and then I go you up and you go
yeah bro lol and you send me a picture a
video of a Russian man wrestling a bear
it made its way across the internet
today and I felt like sharing it yeah
you sent me a lot of bear videos man a
lot of bear related media yeah cuz it's
a bear it's usually a giant bear
sometimes like a picture of a bear and
it's just waving behind a tree
yeah right it'll take phone call 9
podcast and then alright and then I get
and then I'll be like alright dude
whatever and then I get a bear ripping
into a carcass or killing an animal yeah
or
or the how about that polar bear with
the beheaded cow yeah that was a funny
one yeah and you know what you're saying
is that you're a bear and then you're
gonna do that to me that's what you're
saying with imagery what I'm yeah just
the you're a beheaded cow in a way Bryan
the beheaded cow Callen you kinda has a
ring to it no it does it Ryan's the
beheaded Cal Cal I don't think that
hasn't liked that a lot don't think it
has a ring to it you've got a lot of
[ __ ] cool nicknames none as cool as
Bryant the beheaded cow Alan I don't
like it I think if there's anything they
off your that's not stirs and your eyes
enlarge could help you with just two
further things along and you know show
that you know what's up you got cool
things like nicknames Brian the beheaded
cow Callen all right well I just think
it's a little close you know what you
could call your next comedy special what
Oh chop [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and then I get
this 4:00 p.m. cool I go yeah you go Kay
what hold on why are you reading this
cuz I just want to go through this you
go Kay Shh and then I go no don't do
that yeah you go we're gonna enjoy some
silence today I did say no [ __ ] you and
you go [ __ ] you bro I go dude then you
go I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
I didn't mean that I said why'd you said
shut up I said anyway either way it's
been nothing but [ __ ] aggression yeah
well that's interesting that I did say
we're gonna share some silence today
yeah wow that's press quite
subconsciously that came out it's fresh
it's what in a way maybe I manifested
this well maybe maybe I was late today
yeah in a way that wasn't my fault so
that I could just get aggression I this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]